was leute herzlich willkommen zum
kleinen info video
ich wollte euch nur bescheid geben dass
ich jetzt eine art gefälle seite ab auf
der mir auch fragen stellen könnt das
heißt wenn ihr bock habe ich irgendwas
fragen wollt könnt ihr in die kommentare
schreiben aber ich hoffe wie vor auch
auf us camp vorbei stellt mir darauf
fragen habe ich bock drauf und ich war
noch kurz ankündigen dass ich heute ein
kleines café über video gemacht habe mit
dem moment gerade fern
das alles kann viel video so richtig
lustig oder maxis lebens format und ja
schon fast vorbei und links im
beschreibung trennscheibe und dann
mach's gut a3 und